So, um
jumping in, administrative stuff.
So, as you know,
uh we're almost to the end of the
course.
So, here's what we have left in this
last week. Uh so, there's today.
Um this is lecture 17. Like I said,
we're going to talk about MapReduce.
And then also, we're going to start
talking about the math behind replica
conflict resolution.
And if we finish all that today, then uh
we'll have all of Thursday left just for
answering your questions leading up to
the final. And then we'll do an AMA. So,
anything that you want to ask me, you
can ask me whether it has to do with the
course or not. Um
I can't promise I'll answer every
question, but you can certainly ask
them.
Friday, your fourth programming
assignment will be due.
And then next week Thursday is our
final.
Uh so, the final exam, you'll have 3
hours to do it um at a minimum.
Uh more if you have extended time on the
exam, and it'll be uh
not that much longer than the midterm
in terms of the number of questions on
it. So, it'll be worth 120 points as
opposed to 100, which what the midterm
was worth. Uh but, you'll have
relatively speaking a lot more time to
do it.
I don't know if y'all can hear, but my
daughter is saying hello to me. Hi.
She's standing outside the window.
All right. Um so,
just one note about this last uh
programming assignment. So, a part of
the fourth programming assignment is to
do the peer assessment. So, if you
haven't taken a look at this form yet,
uh this is the peer assessment form that
I'm asking you all to fill out to assess
your teammates' contributions to your
team. Thanks to those of you who have
done this already.
Uh a few of you already have.
Uh if you haven't yet, this is linked
from the assignment description and it's
also linked from an announcement on
Zulip.
Uh it shouldn't take you too long to
fill out. So, we're asking a handful of
questions uh which are all
multiple-choice questions and we're
asking uh you to evaluate Let Let me be
clear. We're not asking you to evaluate
your teammate as a person.
We're not asking for that. We're asking
you to evaluate in the context of this
particular project uh
what contributions did your teammate
make?
So, um
your teammate could be a lovely person
or an awful person. We're not asking
about that. We're asking in this
particular narrow project context, we're
asking you to evaluate the contributions
of your teammate. And this includes
questions like was their behavior
cooperative and helpful? Did they do
their share of the work?
Were they actively participating in the
team? Did they listen to and support
others on the team? And did they do
their work accurately and on time? So,
please take a few minutes to fill this
out for every member of your team. And
to motivate you to do it, uh we will not
return your grade for assignment four
until after you've submitted this peer
assessment for every teammate.
So, please give a little bit of
attention to that. It's It should be
easy. It should only take a few minutes.
Uh great question. Will you have any
sort of study guide for the final? I am
going to share a list of questions. So,
uh like I did before, I'll share the
list of the uh in-class uh lecture
quizzes,
uh the questions from those, but I'll
also share a big list of questions that
uh
was put together over the last few years
that I've been teaching this course.
Uh and you'll be able to use that as a
study guide for the the It'll cover the
whole term.
Other logistical questions about this
stuff?
Oh yeah, while you're uh
while I'm I'm talking about uh
assessment, peer assessment, um
be sure to fill out your course
evaluation, also.
And
all I have to say about that is
uh
actionable feedback is good. So, I
really want feedback on what worked and
what didn't for you in this course. So,
if if you have uh
suggestions on what can be done better,
you know, we're eager to hear them. I'm
hoping to get uh
actionable feedback, though. So, instead
of just
something like I didn't like the
assignments, talk about what
specifically you might not have liked
and what specifically you would want
done differently.
And then just stuff like, you know,
there's some stuff that I obviously
can't control, right? Like, if you
didn't like the time that the course
meets, I mean, sorry, I feel for you,
but that's not the sort of thing that is
that I have any power over. So, that's
not something that it's necessarily
useful to talk about on the on the
course evaluation. Talk about stuff that
I actually do have
control over, and then, you know, that
feedback will be taken into account, and
we will uh
and I you know, I'm planning to teach
this course again in the fall. So, the
the better feedback that you can give,
the better this course will be for the
next generation.
All right, let's jump in.
Okay, so we're going to wrap up and
recap uh our discussion of MapReduce
from last time.
So,
to recap from last time, uh somebody
tell me what what are the three phases
of a MapReduce job?
That's right. Yeah, the map the map
phase, the shuffle phase, and the reduce
phase.
Uh so let's let's uh recap the map phase
first.
Uh so that the map phase is when a
programmer supplied map function
runs on all the data.
Here's something that we didn't really
talk about last time. Can somebody tell
me what the type
of the map function is? That is, what is
the type of its input, and what is the
type of its output?
So these might not necessarily be the
literal types that you write in the
code, but conceptually, what is the
input to the map function, and what is
the output?
Okay, takes raw data, gives you derived
data. Yeah, okay. I mean, you're not
wrong, right? But in particular,
what what is the shape of the data that
the map function operates on? So
conceptually, here's the type of map.
It's going to take one
input
key value pair.
And then what is it going to give you as
a result?
So just for example, it might be
something like if we were looking at the
same example we had last time, we might
have something like document one and
then
the quick
brown fox, etc.
And then what would you get back?
That's right. You would get You would
get a set of intermediate key-value
pairs.
So in this case
uh
those intermediate key-value pairs, if
we were doing the example from last time
where we where we talked about uh
uh creating a a an inverted index, it
would be something like
pairing up uh words from the original
document
uh with document identifiers like this.
So a set of those.
So that's This up here at the top is a
particular example
of what the input and output might look
like
uh for a particular MapReduce MapReduce
job. And then this here is the general
uh conceptual type of of the of map.
What if we wanted to do word count
instead? So what would we want the map
function to spit out then?
Well, if it were word count, then we'd
want it to spit out each word
and then a count, right?
So this would be another kind of uh
set of intermediate key-value pairs that
you might get.
So,
in this example, let's say the whole
sentence was
the quick brown fox jumped over the
fence, right? So, there's two
occurrences of the,
but I just put one here, right?
So, I'm imagining that later on
in this set, there would be another
pair.
So, all of those occurrences of the
we're imagining are going to be added
together later. So, it's okay to defer
that until the reduced phase. But, if we
felt like doing it here in the map phase
as an optimization, we could.
Okay.
What happens after the map phase is the
shuffle phase.
And can somebody just summarize what
goes on during the shuffle phase?
Right. Data is hashed to a node and sent
there. Yeah, so that's when the data
from every map worker
is going to go onto the reduced worker
that will process it.
And by data, I mean those intermediate
uh key value pairs.
How is it decided which intermediate key
value pairs go on to which reduce
worker?
Well, that's decided by some
partitioning function.
So, this might do something like
hash hash of key
mod R, where R is the number of reduced
workers.
So, interestingly in the paper,
um
they don't say that the default
partitioning function is this, right? Uh
they don't say that it's necessarily
hash of key mod R. They do say that
there is a default partitioning
function.
They say that the the default
partitioning function uses hashing. And
then they say, "For example, hash of key
mod R." But they don't come out and say
that that's actually it. So,
maybe Google has some secret
uh partitioning by hash approach that
they're not telling us about that's
really awesome, but it's probably
something a lot like this.
Um
and just to reiterate what we said at at
uh last time,
um so, last time we talked about why
would they do this? Like why is it okay
to do this? Because remember when we
discussed consistent hashing,
we talked about how this would be a bad
way to divide up the data if this number
R ever changes.
But we talked about how last time
this isn't necessarily a problem for
MapReduce because in this setting
this number of reduce workers isn't
something that's going to be changing
dynamically hopefully during the
MapReduce job. So it's okay.
Okay, so
that's the shuffle phase.
After the shuffle phase, the data has
gotten on to the reduce workers and the
reduce phase can occur.
We talked about the conceptual type of
the map function.
What's the conceptual type of the reduce
function?
By the way, these types of map and
reduce
may not match up exactly with what you
might be used to from functional
programming and the concepts of map and
reduce.
So
if I had a little bit more time, we
could talk about that, but um
and in the past I have
uh
subjected my class to a discussion of
that. Uh
but I won't do that today. Instead,
we'll just talk about what MapReduce
mean in in the context of this paper.
Okay, so this is a little bit trickier,
yeah. So
the reduce workers are each going to
have their own partition of the data,
right?
And we can think of this as you know,
this kind of partitioning approach, hash
of key, partitioning by hash of key. So
every one of these intermediate
key-value pairs with the same key
is going to end up on the same reduce
worker, right? So a reduce worker
running the reduce function is going to
have a bunch of intermediate key-value
pairs
hopefully with the same key, right? Or
it might have
several sets, but if you if there is a
pair with the same key as another pair,
then they will be on the same reduce
worker.
And it's the job of the reduce function
to put them together somehow.
So
we could say that the reduce function
takes
um
a set of key-value pairs
uh
with the constraint that all the keys
are the same,
right?
But the way that they express this in
the paper
is they say that the reduce function
takes one key
and then takes a set of values
uh that go with it.
So the input to the reduce function is a
particular key and then all of the
values that go with that key. And this
is drawn from this set of intermediate
key value pairs.
And then it produces some set of output
values.
And I can't really be any more specific
than that because
we don't know
uh
what it's going to be. It's going to
depend on the specifics of the supplied
uh
uh reduce computation.
So, somebody put in chat uh write to GFS
from reduce replicas. And that is indeed
what the reduce workers do. They write
to GFS. Um
uh but what I was asking you here was
kind of more like what is the what is
the type of the reduce function? So,
let's see some examples. So, for this
inverted index example
an input to the reduce function might be
something like this. It might be like
dog
and then conceptually
it would be
like the set of documents
uh
containing that uh particular word.
And then in this case, the reduce
function doesn't have to do much of
anything. It just writes its output out
to GFS, basically.
So, in this case
the output is basically going to be the
same.
You might recall from the paper, often
the reduce function doesn't have much to
do. And that's kind of the magic
of the shuffle phase.
So, even though the shuffle phase is
just moving data around
it's kind of magical in the way that it
works so nicely to get the data into the
right places so that there's very little
to do often by the time you get to the
reduced phase depending on the
particular MapReduce computation you're
doing.
So,
you know, in practice the way this would
be implemented is like you'd pass um
some kind of an iterator here and it
would have to iterate through all these
values and do something with them.
But the thing that it does with them
could be as simple as just writing them
out to GFS unchanged.
What if it were something like this?
What if we were doing word count? Well,
then you might have something like
dog
and then you'd have these
counts from the set of intermediate
key-value pairs that would be all the
the individual word counts that you had.
So, maybe one document had one
occurrence of dog. Another document had
three occurrences.
Another one had two and so on.
And then the role of the reduced
function would be to add all those
numbers together.
So, in this case it might be like
something like that.
And that would be a count of every
occurrence of dog in every document.
So, the reason why you might end up with
something like
uh three here and two here and something
like this instead of just the number one
is if you were doing that optimization
that we talked about before
uh with using the combiner function up
here during the map phase to do a little
bit of the computation early.
Otherwise, you would just have a list of
ones here.
So, let's talk about that just a tiny
bit.
So, let's say that I'm a map worker.
And let's say that I have to count
occurrences of the word dog.
Um so, let's say
that
for a particular
uh document, I have something like
No.
My dog
is
the best dog
and the fastest dog.
So, let's say that I have this.
If I used the word count map function
that appears in the MapReduce paper,
then
let's say that I were only counting the
occurrences of dog. Let's say that I was
ignoring other words.
So, if I used what was in the paper,
then I would end up with like three
intermediate key key-value pairs here.
I'd end up with this.
And this would be during the map phase,
right?
And then during the shuffle phase,
those would all get sent to a particular
reduce worker.
So, the shuffle phase would send them
uh to some reduce worker.
And then at that point, uh all those
ones would get added together.
And you would end up with
this.
So, I can kind of draw an arrow in the
middle here, so it showing shuffle.
So, this is the map
output.
This is the reduce output.
What is wrong with doing it this way?
Or are there any downsides to doing it
this way?
Yeah, okay.
Good question. Okay, so the question is
in the shuffle phase isn't the map
information supposed to go to all reduce
replicas? So, in general, all of the map
workers are going to have to talk to all
the reduce workers because in general
some of the intermediate key value pairs
produced by a given
uh
uh produced by any given map worker are
going to have to get hashed to a
particular reduce worker.
Um so, yeah. Maybe I mean maybe this
sentence was split over
uh multiple documents, right? Maybe I
had a sentence
that was just my dog is the best dog,
another sentence that was just and the
fastest dog. Maybe these were on
different map workers, right?
And then both of those map workers would
have to talk to the reduce worker that
was responsible for the key dog.
Great. Yeah, so somebody just said what
I was looking for, which was
sending all three of these tuples across
the network uh costs bandwidth, right?
So,
these could have just been added
together on the map worker's side. And
then the map worker could have just sent
this.
So, a map worker is a
uh fully capable of of doing some local
computation.
And then that on the reduce side would
be added together with every other map
worker's count for dog. So, the reduce
worker could still have work to do,
but they'd be adding together
the local counts from a bunch of the map
workers instead of just adding up a
whole bunch of ones.
And this is the notion of using a
combined function.
So, this would be
Uh this would be a way to possibly save
bandwidth if you could do some of this
work on the reduce worker's side,
then you have less to send over
um
to the reduce workers when it's time to
uh to do the shuffle.
The reason this is okay to do
in the case of our word count
computation
is because
the operation that we're doing, in this
case it's addition, right? We're just
adding together these numbers.
This is okay to do because
addition is associative.
So, what does that mean? Uh well,
associativity means
for addition,
it means that if you add A plus B,
right? And then you add C to that,
that's the same as if you add A to the
result of adding B and C.
So, if the reduce operation in general
that you're trying to do, in this case
the reduce operation is addition,
so um
if the reduce operation is associative,
then it's okay to do as much as we can
early
locally on the map workers.
So, the reduce workers will still have
work to do,
but not as much data will have to be
sent during that shuffle phase.
So, in general,
if the reduce function is associative,
then we can do this combine thing and do
some of the work early on.
It's pretty cool. We can save bandwidth
by taking advantage of this
associativity property.
So, instead of sending
dog one a million times, then a map
worker can just do as much addition
locally as possible and then send that
compressed data, in a sense, over to the
appropriate reduce worker.
And then the reduce worker will do
whatever addition is still necessary to
be done at that point to get the final
result.
Questions about any of that?
Okay, so somebody asked a good question
last time, uh, which I I didn't really
answer well. So, I want to try to answer
it a little bit better.
So, the question last time was
um,
why did Google stop using MapReduce?
Oh, somebody just asked, let me let me
re- recap this. So, somebody just asked,
"Why does associativity matter?" Well,
it matters when you do the addition,
right? So,
if the operation were not associative,
right?
Then
it wouldn't be okay for us to do it
early over here on the map workers.
Uh if it weren't associative, then you
might get a different result by doing
some chunk of it early and then doing
the rest of it later.
Uh
but as it turns out, we because it is
associative, doing a chunk early
uh and the rest later gives you the same
result as if you were to do uh
as as if you were to just send all of
the original intermediate key-value
pairs over to the reduced worker for it
to do all of the computation. So
associativity lets you do some of the
computation early on the map workers and
get it over with.
Make sense?
Addition is just one example.
But it's uh it's the one that happens to
be useful in this particular word count
example, but in general
any associative reduce operation should
be okay to do this combined thing with.
Yeah, good question. I don't have off
the top of my head an example of a
non-associative operation where this
would break.
Um I think, you know, the best practice
with using MapReduce is to do something
associative. I only point this out
because if you for whatever reason have
a non-associative operation, then um
uh then you need to be careful about how
you use the MapReduce framework.
Good question.
I'll try to think of a good one. Yeah,
somebody that has an example in chat
about uh finding an average. Yeah.
Good one. Yeah, like averaging things
over here.
Yeah, anytime you're you're taking
averages of averages, you could end up
with something yucky.
Yeah, you're exactly right. Yeah, so a
non-associative operation
Okay, so you're asking, you know, why
wouldn't it not Why would a
non-associative operation ever be okay?
Because wouldn't that mess things up
over here? Well,
as long as
let's say that you are doing a
non-associative operation.
Um
Well,
as long as
all of the um the intermediate key-value
pairs with the same key get sent to the
same reduce worker, and those reduce
workers are deterministic computers,
right? Then you should get the same
result, right? Because I'm So the the
assumption is that a given reduce worker
is going given the same input is going
to do the same computation uh on the
same input.
Um
the issue would be
uh
if you did some pre-computation on some
of the map workers beforehand, then that
would be a different input. So then you
couldn't necessarily expect the same
output from a different input if the
operation were not associative.
Yeah, and this has interesting
implications, right? For um uh
for for for the ability to stream data,
right? Like you would It It's It would
be kind of nice to be able to do
computation in advance. So I'm sure this
is something that comes up more when you
talk about streaming systems.
All right, so I want to talk a little
bit about um
the question that somebody asked at the
end of last time, which I didn't really
have a great answer to off the top of my
head, which is
uh why doesn't Google do MapReduce
anymore? So
um I sort of hand-waved and said, "Well,
they still do." So
MapReduce at Google
uh
didn't so much go away as get
generalized. So
uh you can look up if you want to
uh a paper
uh that came out in 2010.
Uh
uh which is called FlumeJava. I think
it's FlumeJava easy efficient
data parallel pipelines.
And this is about the Flume system, uh
which kind of generalizes MapReduce,
uh and as far as I know it's still in
use at Google. Uh this Yeah, let me put
a date on there. So, this was this was
something like 2010.
So,
why did Flume become necessary?
Well,
we talked about how with MapReduce,
you can do anything you want with
MapReduce as long as it fits into this
particular
structure of map phase, shuffle phase,
reduce phase.
And after the reduce phase, everything
gets written out to
uh to storage, to GFS in the case of of
um of MapReduce. So,
this works great if the computation that
you have to do fits nicely into that
particular structure.
Uh but some computations are harder than
others to kind of shoehorn into that
structure. And what you end up having to
do
uh is have
a sort of series of of MapReduce
computations in order to compute what
you actually want to compute. So, what
you might end up doing is have like
uh
a MapReduce job
that then produces input to another
MapReduce job
and so on, right? So,
the raw data comes in this end.
And then in order to
compute what you need to compute,
because the MapReduce framework is so
structured and because there's there's
only so much
uh you can do, right? You're given only
a couple of degrees of freedom with the
MapReduce framework. You get to supply
the map function and reduce function.
If you need to compute something that
doesn't fit into that framework, then
you need to chain together multiple
phases of MapReduce.
What happens in between MapReduce jobs?
Well,
the data gets written out to GFS, right?
So, in between here and here, you're
writing out the data to GFS, and then it
goes back in.
And then again here.
And then back in here.
So,
if these different MapReduce jobs are
each just themselves intermediate stages
in the overall pipeline that you're
trying to uh
to carry out, then this gets really
tiresome, right? Because you're having
to write out the data to uh the the file
system in between every one of these
intermediate phases. So, this gets
really slow. Instead of just able to
keep the data on the machines that are
operating on it, instead it's being
written out to this intermediate storage
location every time, and then sucked
right back into MapReduce, and then out
to storage again, and then back in. So,
this gets really slow. So, what you
might hope for instead is some kind of
kind of system that offered you a little
bit more flexibility,
uh that would let you um
not have to do this writing out to
intermediate storage every time.
Uh, so that is what Flume does.
Uh, so Flume generalizes MapReduce. If
you still just want to do a regular old
MapReduce job, you can.
Um, but Flume also makes it possible to
schedule these long chains of MapReduce
jobs uh, in a way that's more efficient.
And so, if you're interested, I I would
encourage you to to check out that paper
that I mentioned. Um, and there may have
been things published more recently,
too. I'm actually not sure. Um, but uh,
um,
it's uh, it's a nice paper. I remember
reading it a few years after it came
out.
Uh, so it's not so much that MapReduce
has gone away. It's just that it's been
generalized and um,
uh,
this this particular limitation of it
has kind of been overcome.
Okay. That's about all I have to say
about MapReduce.
Um, yeah, interesting conversation going
on in the chat about about possible um,
non-associative operations.
All right. Next thing I want to talk
about.
I'm trying to think if I should do the
quiz question right now. Yeah, let's go
ahead and do our quiz before I move on
to the next topic.
All right.
Yeah, let's take our 10-minute break
now, slightly earlier than usual.
And I will see you again
at 4:10.
Mhm.
All right, 2-minute warning.
Okay, welcome back.
All right, so I want to talk about
something different.
I'm going to talk about the math behind
replica conflict resolution, but before
I do that,
I want to talk about
consensus for just a moment to set the
stage.
In particular, I want to talk about the
cost of consensus. So,
this is something that we might have
discussed a little a while ago, but I
want to cover it in more depth. So,
in this course, we've obviously spent a
lot of time talking about
replica consistency, right? We've talked
about the problem of keeping replicas
consistent.
So, quite often, the situation is that
you have some number of replicas.
Let's just say two like this to keep it
simple.
And um you have updates coming in,
or you have some sort of messages
arriving at these replicas that causes
some kind of a change in state.
And let's say that both of these
replicas can receive updates. Just like
with the key-value store that you've
implemented,
any replica can receive and deliver
updates.
At least that's what you were supposed
to implement.
So, this is a scenario where there's no
leader. We aren't doing primary backup
or anything like that. Neither replica
is special.
So, updates could come in here. Maybe
this
replica could get a message saying A,
and this one could get a message saying
B.
In this kind of a scenario,
if we want strong consistency,
what are our options?
Well,
we could use a consensus protocol to
decide where to slot in every event as
it arrives. So, let's say we have
something like this where replica one
receives this
uh
update A,
and replica two receives this this
update B.
Well, then we could run consensus,
right? Maybe we have Paxos.
So, maybe over here we have some
acceptors, right?
So,
maybe R1 is acting as a proposer and it
can say, "I propose that we put event A
in slot one."
And meanwhile, replica two
might be saying, "I propose that we put
event B in slot one."
Well, one of those will win, right?
Uh
either that or the Paxos uh algorithm
won't terminate. Uh
and then in which case there might be
some time out and you'd have to start
over, but we know that it won't end with
these two replicas having different
things in slot one. That's the agreement
part of those properties of agreement,
validity, and termination.
Okay, so
let's say
that
these two replicas are trying to decide
what what goes into slots. Maybe maybe
it would look something like this. Maybe
replica one is saying
uh well, I want to propose that A goes
in. Well, first it has to send a prepare
message, right? So, it's going to send
its prepare message over here to
majority of acceptors.
And then it has to hear back and
meanwhile B is also sending its prepare
message.
Maybe it's sending them here. So, maybe
these got
uh these got ignored, right? Because
these got responded to.
So, maybe these two got ignored.
Maybe this was like a
uh
eh, I don't know what proposer number
was used, but point is somebody got in
first and then the other ones got
ignored. So,
promise messages go back, then A gets to
say what it wants to have accepted. So,
A would say, "Oh, I want to have
my message A going in slot one, so it'll
send that out.
Then it'll get a response there.
And then that information is also going
to get broadcast to B
because B is a learner in this case.
So,
look at all these messages.
How many messages got sent here? A whole
lot, right? It looks like
Uh
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 Something like
12 messages were sent just to get to the
point where both R1 and R2 knew to put A
in slot one.
And we still have to run the protocol
again to get them to agree to put
message B in slot two.
So, the point here is consensus
protocols are expensive, right? The only
time that you really, really want to use
them is when it's very important that
everyone agrees on it having everything
in exactly the same order.
So, in this case,
we would only want to go to the trouble
of agreeing on an order for A and B if
it actually matters that they do happen
in the same order everywhere.
Now, I haven't told you anything about
what these A and B are, right?
Um so,
it's possible that it is really
important that they do happen in an
order
uh that's important, right? And it's
it's necessary for everybody to agree on
that.
So, quite often in this class, we've
talked about events or messages without
talking about the content of those
events or messages.
So,
most of the time, like when we're
talking about
uh
things like Paxos, when we're talking
about deciding on the order in which
these events go,
we don't need to know anything about
what those events do in order for Paxos
to make that decision, right? The
algorithm doesn't care.
Likewise, when we talked about causal
broadcast, it's deciding it
whether to delay or deliver a message
based on the causal metadata attached to
that message. The causal broadcast
algorithm doesn't care about the actual
content of the message. It only cares
about that causal metadata.
It doesn't care if those messages are
you know, checking your account balance
or launching rockets or whatever.
And Paxos doesn't care about what these
events A and B are.
The Chandy-Lamport algorithm doesn't
care. None of these algorithms care
about the actual content of the
messages.
So,
in fact, because these algorithms are so
general and they have to work regardless
of the content of the messages or the
content of the events,
it wouldn't make any sense for these
algorithms to sort of look inside these
messages and look at the message
contents. What could they even do,
right? They couldn't do anything
necessarily useful with that information
because these algorithms have to work
generally uh
uh
with any kind of messages.
But, for you as a human being who's
developing applications that might be
interacting with this replicated system,
well,
you know what your messages say. You
know what your messages mean.
And you know what application-specific
properties you need to enforce and which
ones you don't care about, right?
So, to come back to our standard
example, right?
What if R1 and R2 are copies of a
shopping cart?
And what if events A and B are adding
things to the cart?
Let's say that event A is adding a book
to the cart and event B is adding a
blender to the cart. Well,
if that's what's going on here,
then you probably don't want to pay the
cost of sending all of these messages
just to get everybody to agree, okay,
first we're going to add the pants and
then we're going to add the blender,
right? Because that would be massive
overkill for this situation.
Because the order doesn't really matter
very much. No.
The guarantee that you want could vary
depending on the application that you're
actually implementing.
But,
a lot of the time,
the safety property that you want is not
strong consistency.
I'm going to argue that a lot of the
time, the safety property that you want
is just strong convergence.
Not strong consistency.
So, recall that strong convergence means
that
if replicas have delivered the same set
of updates, then their states agree.
The same set in any order.
So, strong consistency is going to be
overkill for a lot of situations.
So, if you need this if you need this
property,
then
your life gets a lot easier, right?
You don't have to make sure that people
get the same updates in the same order.
You just need to make sure that
if a replica gets a certain set of
updates in a certain order, then its
state
is going to be the same as the state of
another replica who might have gotten
the same set of updates
in different order.
That might still be a challenge, but
it's a heck of a lot easier than making
sure that everybody gets all the updates
in exactly the same order.
Okay, so if we if we have replicas
repre- representing shopping carts, and
we have if we have events that are
adding items to carts,
then
to have replicas agree,
we just want to make sure that
the same set of events shows at ev-
shows up at every replica in some order,
right? And then if we have strong
convergence, right? That tells us that
the replicas will agree at the moment
that they've gotten the same set of
updates.
So, that's shopping carts.
But what is the general principle here?
The general principle. We know what to
do for shopping carts, but how do we
generalize that? So, for this, we need
to add a little bit of math,
but it's math that you've seen already.
Uh
or at least most of it is.
So,
let's talk a little bit about it. So,
reach back in your brain to when we
talked about partially ordered sets
way back at the beginning of the course.
Uh can somebody remind me of what the
definition of a partially ordered set
is?
Or a poset for short, as some people
call it.
That's right. Yeah, so you have a set.
Call it S.
Together with a binary relation.
And I'll write it this way.
Sort of looks like less than or equal
to, but it'll I'll use this uh
uh funny-looking uh square
uh
operator.
Uh that relates some of the elements of
S to each other. So, the partially
ordered part of partially ordered set
means that not every pair of elements in
S is necessarily going to be related by
the relation. In other words, not every
pair of elements is going to be
necessarily comparable.
Um
but this is going to be a relation that
relates
elements of S to each other. And in a
partial order, there are some axioms
that have to hold for this relation.
And there are three of them.
Can anybody remind me what the three
properties are that have to be true of
that uh of that relation?
Yeah, that's right.
So, the partial order
has to be reflexive.
So, this means
for all the elements of S,
uh they're all related to themselves by
the partial order.
Antisymmetry.
So, this says that if you have
a couple of elements of S,
A and B, if A is related to B by the
partial order and B is related to A,
uh
then they're the same.
And then finally,
transitivity,
which says that
for all elements of S, A, B, and C, if
you have A related to B
and B related to C,
then
A is related to C.
What's an example
of a partially ordered set? Well, the
usual go-to example for explaining
partial orders is
to have S be
the set of all subsets of some other
set. So,
if we're talking about items in our
online store,
like, you know, books
and blenders
and pants,
then
we could talk about the set of all
subsets of that set.
So,
I could say S is
maybe there would be the empty set, and
there would be the set containing the
book,
and the set containing the blender,
and the set containing the pants.
Then you have pairs of two. So, like
we've got the book
and the blender.
And we've got the book and the pants.
I hope you like my art.
What else do we need?
Uh whoops, not the book. We already got
that. We need the blender and the pants.
And then the finally the set of all
three.
So, that's S.
It's got eight elements, all of the
subsets of this of this set.
And the relation, so if that's S, now we
need to talk about the binary relation.
And the binary relation we care about in
this case is uh set inclusion.
So,
for instance,
this set
would be a subset of this set.
So, this would be two elements of S that
are in fact related by the binary
relation. But,
you could have other elements of S that
are not related. For example,
the set containing just the pants
is not a subset of the set containing
just the blender.
And
nor is the set containing just the
blender a subset of the set containing
just the pants. So, this is a partial
order rather than a total order
because there are some pairs of elements
of S that are not related
by this ordering relation. Okay.
This is all review so far.
But now we have the pieces in place to
be able to talk about something new.
So we can talk about upper bounds.
We can pick out
any two elements of our set S and we can
ask
which elements
of S are at least as big as both of
those according to the ordering
relation. So if let's say that I pick
the set containing just the book
and I pick the set containing just the
pants.
What are the elements of S that are at
least as big as both of those?
So here again is the entire set S.
So what elements of S are at least as
big as this element of S and also this
element of S?
Hmm.
Somebody says just the mug. Okay, so
maybe there's a misunderstanding because
what we're looking for are elements of S
that are bigger according to this
uh
binary relation here. So, here we said
that
um
the pants are less than the set
containing the pants and the blender.
Which probably looks a little bit more
like a mug.
Um
so what we want are elements of S that
are at least as big as both of these.
So, they have to be elements of S that
you know, at a minimum they have to
contain both of these.
And when we say as big as
we mean
according to this relation.
So, I didn't write out the whole
definition of our set inclusion
relation. Um but I'm hoping that it's
fairly intuitive.
Okay, yeah. So,
Hmm, the set with the mug and the pants?
Well, that's not at least as big as both
of these because oh, maybe you couldn't
tell what this is a picture of. This is
supposed to be a picture of the book.
So, elements of S that are at least as
big as both of these include
first of all, this set that has both the
the book and the pants. That's at least
as big as both of those.
And then also the set of all three,
right?
Right.
So, somebody just said it in chat.
Yeah.
So, these are called upper bounds
of these other two elements
of S.
So, here's the definition.
Given a partially ordered set,
an upper bound
of a particular pair of elements
in S
is some element in S
call it U
such that
A is less than U according to the
relation and B is less than or equal
according to the relation.
Or you can pronounce it less than or
than or equal to.
So
a given pair of elements in S might have
many upper bounds.
But
in general, the upper bounds that are
going to be interesting to us
are going to be the smallest ones. So in
this case, this is the upper bound.
These are both upper bounds, but this is
the upper bound that's really
interesting.
So
we can formally define what it means for
an upper bound to be the smallest.
So we can say
an upper bound
of a particular pair of elements is
what we call the least upper bound.
Or lub for short, or sometimes called
the join.
If
let's call it U here. An upper bound U
uh
if
U is less than or equal to V.
for
each upper bound
V
of A and B.
So, in this case, the least upper bound
of the set containing the book and the
set containing the pants is going to be
this one, the set containing the book
and the set containing the pants. This
is also an upper bound
of those two elements, but it's not the
least upper bound. So, this here is the
least upper bound.
In this partially ordered set that we've
been talking about,
let me ask you this.
Do every two elements have a least upper
bound?
Uh somebody asked in chat, "Does this
join have anything to do with the notion
of join from relational databases?" Uh
I'll let that one be an exercise for the
reader.
All right. So, in our set S, which is
the set of all subsets of this um
uh
of the set of of book, pants, and
blender, do every two elements have a
least upper bound?
It's kind of a tricky one. So, I'll give
away the answer. Turns out that yes,
they do.
So, now we can define
a partially ordered set
in which
every two elements have a least upper
bound
has a fancy name.
It's called
a join
semi-lattice.
A lot of partially ordered sets turn out
to be join semi-lattices.
So, to bring this back to distributed
systems,
if we have our two replicas, right?
And we have a couple of clients.
Let's say
that we have a partially ordered set
that is not a joint semilattice. So,
let's say that we have one where
not every two elements have a least
upper bound.
It's actually a little bit tricky to
think of one.
But,
I have an example in mind. So, here's
one.
So, let's say that you have
uh
a register that can be either empty
or it could be filled in with either
true or false.
So, these are the different states that
it can be in.
And I drew it like this to show
that the different So, so we have a set
here of of possible states. There's
empty, true, and false.
And
so,
is it a partially ordered set? Well, we
can check that it is, right? Uh it turns
out that it's reflexive, antisymmetric,
and transitive. So, the relation here
would be like,
you know, empty
is less than true,
and empty is less than false.
Um
true is less than or equal to true,
false is less than or equal to false,
empty is less than or equal to empty.
So, it's it's reflexive.
Um
So, it ends up being a partially ordered
set, but it's not
a a joint semilattice because these two
elements, true and false, don't have a
least upper bound.
So,
in our example,
if these are our clients,
let's say that this client here
has sent a message
saying
set the register to true.
And maybe this one has sent a message
saying set the register to false.
So now we're in trouble, right? Because
we don't have a way to combine true and
false.
They don't have a least upper bound.
So in this case
replica one got the true message first
and then the false message. So replica
one might end up
in the false state, while replica two
might end up in the true state.
So if this is the situation that you're
in
then you might end up needing to do
something like consensus in order to
resolve this problem.
But
if we had had two elements that did have
a least upper bound
then we wouldn't have a problem here
because
then when you get this message
you could merely combine this other
message with it. Right?
And then here similarly.
So I'm going to make an informal claim.
So my claim is that
if the states that a replica can take on
are the elements of a join semilattice
then you have a natural way of resolving
conflicts between replicas
without having to do consensus.
And we've talked about this before, but
let's just look at it.
So, if we had, for instance,
our situation where
somebody writes
the book
and somebody else writes
the pants
like so.
Then,
when these updates arrive,
they don't have to clobber each other.
Instead, the replicas can build on the
state that they have.
So, replica one here
can merge together
the result of this right and the result
of this right to get
something like this
and similarly here.
And the reason why this is possible
is because
the states that these replicas can take
on
are elements of a join semilattice. And
the particular join semilattice that it
is is that set S that we were talking
about before
and the set inclusion operation.
And that gives us a way of resolving
conflicts between replicas without
having to do consensus.
And you can think about that yourself
and think about whether it makes sense.
Um but if you're interested in these
kinds of ideas,
um I'd recommend looking up
on your own uh something called
conflict-free
replicated data types.
Or CRDTs.
So, CRDTs are data structures that are
designed for replication.
The particular flavor of CRDTs that I've
been showing here are something called
state-based CRDTs.
So, this is a state-based
CRDT example.
What might actually happen in practice
with CRDTs is that
maybe this client is only talking to
replica one.
And maybe this client is only talking to
replica two.
Then what might happen is that at some
point periodically
uh these replicas send each other their
state.
And then they have to merge their state
with the other replica. So, maybe at
some point uh at some point after this
update has been received with this book,
replica one decides to
let replica two know, "Hey,
I got this update."
So, it'll send its state over. Replica
two will merge
that state in with its own.
And when it does that,
how does it do it? It does it by
computing the least upper bound of its
current state and the received state.
And similarly,
replica replica two could send its state
over here.
And replica one could carry out this
merge
by taking the least upper bound of its
current state and the received state.
And at the end of this process,
we will have the property that we
wanted, which was strong convergence. We
won't have strong consistency because
like we talked about in the past, strong
consistency means that clients can't
tell that the data is replicated, right?
And that's not the case here. Because a
client could come along
and read R1 and R2 at some point, you
know, during this phase before the
merging has taken place, right? And if
the client reads during that phase, then
they'll see that the data is not
strongly consistent. So, strong
consistency is not what we're promising
here at all.
Instead, we're only promising strong
convergence.
So, with CRDTs, and in particular what
what these are, state-based CRDTs,
you have this notion that um the states
that replicas can take on are elements
of a joint semilattice, and when you
receive uh an update from another
replica, you can merge it in to your own
by taking the least upper bound.
Why can you always do that? Because the
in the definition of a joint semilattice
is that every two elements have a least
upper bound.
And so, that makes it possible to do
that merge and have it always uh
come out like it should.
So, here's one last thing to think
about.
Uh so far,
I've been talking about
issues that can arise
when you're adding different items to a
set. And in this in particular, this
sort of issue might occur if there was a
network partition, right?
Maybe client one could only talk to
replica one, right? And maybe client two
could only talk to replica two.
So,
you want it to be the case that later on
when that network partition heals, that
their states are able to come to an
agreement.
But so far I've only been talking about
adding items to a set. But if clients
want to be able to remove items. Yeah,
exactly. Thank you for asking the
question. Then things get even more
complicated. So, think about how in the
Dynamo paper, deleted items could
reappear in shopping carts.
Why did that happen? Well,
it could happen because
if you're representing the contents of a
cart as a set, right?
And the conflict resolution is going to
take the set union of multiple versions
of the cart, maybe an item has been
deleted from somebody's copy, but it
hasn't been deleted from somebody else's
copy yet.
If that delete hasn't propagated
everywhere yet, then the item could
reappear when that older replica gets
unioned together with the newer one. If
somebody if anybody out there still had
the old copy, then it's going to end up
in that union, right?
Well, it turns out there are some tricks
for handling this. And um
the CRDT people uh came up with some of
them. So, this is work that happened uh
the the the the original paper on this
came out in 2011,
which you'll note is a few years after
Dynamo. Um and then a there's kind of a
lot more work in this space has happened
over the last 10 years.
So,
what are some of the tricks that you can
do to deal with removing things? In
general, the problem of deletion is
tricky. So, one of those tricks
is to separately keep track of
everything that's been deleted, right?
So, then you essentially need two sets,
right? You need one to keep track of
everything that's been added, and then
you need another set to keep track of
everything that's been deleted.
And then when you have to sync up
replicas,
you have to take the union of the sets
of items that have been added and take
the union of the sets of items that have
been deleted.
So, the the merge needs to be a little
bit more sophisticated in that case.
So, this helps, but it doesn't actually
solve all your problems, right? Because
like let's say what if you add something
and then you delete it and then you add
it again.
Well,
then what do you do, right? Now it's in
both your addition set and it's in your
removal set.
Which of those wins?
Right? Well, a common approach is to say
remove wins.
And then
basically it means that if you add
something and then you delete it, you
can't ever add it again.
So, that might or might not be the
semantics that you actually want for
your application.
So, then you could try keeping a count
of times that something has been added
or deleted.
Another question in chat, who keeps the
set of added and removed elements?
Uh yeah, so the question is
yeah, who keeps track? Um
well, yeah, every replica indeed has to
track both additions and removals. So,
um this this obviously gets to be a lot
of state, doesn't it?
And that's one of the issues, right?
With CRDTs is that you're tracking a lot
of state, especially if you're doing a
lot of deletions, right?
The the sets of deleted elements are
called tombstone sets.
Because they
uh they're like markers for, you know,
RIP this element of the set, right? And
some people uh jokingly call them
doomstone sets because they're so
unpleasant to have to keep around.
So,
CRDTs do not solve all your problems.
They're
nice, right? And they can help you avoid
certain kinds of bugs, but
sometimes
uh
there but there are some issues that are
ultimately unavoid- unavoidable and
might require you to do something like
eventually garbage collect all of the
tombstone, right? And to do that,
you might need to do consensus and get
everybody to agree on a particular point
where you're going to do that garbage
collection.
In summary, distributed systems are
hard.
All right. So, that's food for thought.
Um
thinking about how you manage this sort
of replicated state in a setting where
you also have to deal with network
partitions and you don't want to have to
do consensus all the time.
Uh if you want to talk more about this
stuff, I love talking about it, uh but
we're unfortunately out of time for
today.
I will see you on Thursday
and we're going to spend our time doing
review for the final. So, bring your
questions and also bring anything at all
that you might want to ask me.
And enjoy the rest of um assignment
four.
And I look forward to seeing you in a
couple days. Take care.